todos los caminos en la llave conducen a
la mezquita del imam ali el yerno del
profeta mahoma y con quien inicia el
chiísmo la rama del islam mayoritaria en
irak
al baba esta iniciativa del papá de
visitar al ayatolá si están y será un
camino para acercar el entendimiento
sobre el islam del eslavo este santuario
es el lugar más sagrado para los chiítas
después de la meca y medina en arabia
saudita hasta que llegan millones de
peregrinos cada año y en estos
corredores se educan los críticos bajo
la tutela de los grandes ayatolás
incluido alistan y la máxima figura
religiosa de nayaf y de irak que por su
avanzada edad se le ve muy poco en la
ciudad el papa visitará asisten ya en
nayaf ambos comparten los mismos
principios el amor la paz el respeto a
la humanidad el respeto a ellos mismos
esta librería tuvo una sección
clandestina durante la dictadura de
sadam husein cuando se libró una campaña
para silenciar a los chiítas
especialmente a la causa o seminario de
nayaf esto llevó a que la ciudad y su
visión del chiísmo fuera pagada por como
el centro de esta rama del islam en irán
donde los clérigos chiítas gobiernan
desde 1979 sidebar al un considera que
los seminarios de nayaf y como lo están
incompetencia pero si tienen divisiones
intelectuales una de ellas es sobre la
religión el estado sobre la que nadie
defiende su separación
venimos de un periodo en el que
estábamos alejados del mundo estábamos
encerrados aquí ahora esta visita pondrá
el foco en nayaf y el mundo se
preguntará qué significan allá va
años atrás el papá se acercó a los
líderes del sunismo la secta mayoritaria
el islam en el mundo en un intento por
establecer un diálogo entre religiones
ahora se lo mismo con la causa de nayaf
un reconocimiento que muchos chiítas
celebran como un triunfo en irak